à la capitale ukrainienne a survécu la
deuxième nuit de la guerre et
je pense que tous les tous les habitants
sont très grave parce qu'il n'y a pas de
panique dame de citer beaucoup de gens
ont
passé la nuit dans les abris souterrains
je peux voir de le combat de mon balcon
parce que le combat de rue à bâle lyon
de kiev près de plus de moi vingt
kilomètres de mon appartement donc vous
voulez vous les voyez vous les entendez
je l'entendais je peux vous voir le
missile ukrainienne lancé aux directions
de la rapport aux taux mail 7 ans et un
petit a rappelé qu'ils étaient utilisés
par les russes pour
pour
ils ont ils ont fait d'eux ils ont été
utilisés pour
pour attaquer la capitale
l'attak qui a essuyé il y a mais le
combat continue à ce bal lieu dans la
direction nord ouest de kiev donc à
l'heure qu'il est s'agripper tokoph vous
fait état de ces combats mais aussi de
de la résilience de la population qu'en
est il des combattants par exemple des
réservistes des civils auquel le
président de lens qui a fait appel qu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
hier je suis allée dans le dans le
centre de réservistes pour avoir que ce
que je pouvais faire il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui on rajeunit de
l'armée craignant nous nous continuerons
comme d'habitude il y à l'électricité
lanterner le supermarché ici à quartier
étaient
fermées il n'y a mais ils ont réouvert
aujourd'hui il ya de gens je vois les
gens qui attend le vert' de supermarché
il y à de jeunes partout à plusieurs
parfois on écoute de sirènes et le j'en
sors de des bâtiments pour aller à
l'abri souterrain mais en a mais à part
de ça nous nous résisterons nous
soutiendrons au soutien de l'armée
ukrainienne et
c'est ça que vous inspire votre
président volodymyr zelensky on a
diffusé tout al'air sa déclaration où il
se filme devant un bâtiment de kiev la
maison aux chimères je crois qu'est-ce
qu'il vous inspire votre chef de l'état
c'est un chef de guerre il vous
supportent ils vous soutiens vous en
êtes content en ce moment tous les
ukrainiens support le gouvernement il
n'y a pas de différences politiques à
ces moments ne sont usés ni en face de
la question'' russe s est vraiment
vraiment difficile c'est vraiment le
moment de
important pour les pays
et à leurs vies ne sont je pense que
nous sommes tous courage 1 il n'y a pas
de panique les russes espérant qu'ils
aient que les ukrainiens ont paniqué
quitté le désarment quitté des cités ça
n'arrivera pas et alors je pense que
déjà les rues seront
on ne vont pas gagner